your psychology actually dictates the
success of your company and everyone
who's there working for a mission that
you really care about your conviction
and confidence really is what influences
the outcomes
hi I'm Marcellus apone I'm 29 and I'm
the CEO and co-founder of hello Alfred
so I met my co-founder Jessica Beck at
Harvard Business School we were thinking
about going back into careers where we
worked in finance and banking and
consulting and it was really long work
weeks and so this idea of having someone
who came every week to help us with
things that just are reoccurring like
our groceries and our dry-cleaning so we
built it for ourselves we had to let me
come and help us every week and our
friends got wind of it and wanted in as
well we thought maybe there's something
there
so hello Alfred is the way of bringing
an entire support system together and
helping with all the things you need to
get done in your life I think having a
co-founder is the best possible thing
you can do especially if you can find
someone who complements you really well
and amplifies the stuff that you are
best at in the world so what we say
about each other is I start fires and
she puts them out or maintains as
necessary consumer tech has been
traditionally a man's game and I think
the weight thing about it is to make it
a genderless game and suggest have
really high aspirations and ignore
critics and I think women start
businesses that seem cute on the surface
but that's when you should be really
afraid because there's usually something
deeper underneath because what we're
doing is really meaningful and is it
going to change how people
you